How you doing? I'm good, and you?
I'm pretty good, thank you. Thank you.
You're You're a Muslim, is that correct?
Yes, and I'm and I'm proud of being a
Muslim. Okay. Awesome. Did you hear the
Did you hear the question that I asked
the brother? Yeah, I'm hearing you.
So, can can Allah have a son without a
mate? No. Thank you. That's it. You see
how easy that was? You see how easy that
was? Yes, that's my answer. But Allah
Allah is not because what is the first
question you you have to ask yourself
first is
what is son? Isn't it? You should You
should ask yourself. No one can create
son. Isn't it?
You can't create son. You have to have
intimacy with a lady first before you
before you get a son. Isn't it? I would
dis- I would disagree. Why? All right.
Why? Why are you going to disagree?
Okay. All right. For example All right.
Jesus
You believe that Jesus is the son of
Mary, right? Yes. Even in the Quran it
is it was stated like that. Exactly. You
know You know it's a miracle, yes.
Right. So, so Mary did not have
intercourse in order to bear her son.
So, you can be a son without, you know,
intercourse. Yes, and that was because
Allah instructed Allah instructed that.
Even in the Quran it was Wait now. In
the Quran it is stated that Allah said
"Kum fayakun." Allah said "Be." And it
And it be. Isn't it?
So, Allah was
Allah was able to say "Be." and it is
and without sexual intercourse Yes.
to cause Mary to give birth to a son
named Jesus.
Yes. Okay. But that doesn't make Jesus
Allah's son. All right, no worries. It
doesn't make Jesus Allah's son. No
worries. So Yes. All I did All I'm
asking is this.
If Mary is able to have a son without
sexual intercourse
can Allah have a son without a
Okay.
What are you saying? I don't I can't
understand you very well. If If Mary, by
the power of Allah, was able to have a
son without sexual intercourse, can can
Allah
have a son without sexual intercourse? I
just I just answered you
uh before earlier before now. I said
Allah Allah does not have a wife. I got
you. Allah
Yes, Allah does not have a wife. I
understand.
So, could he have a son without a wife?
He can't. So, Mary is able to have a son
without a husband, but Allah can't have
a son without a wife. Yes. So,
I got you. Yes. Yes, that's it. That
argument that shows that Allah is not
all powerful, which means he's not God.
Yes, but then what what I want to tell
you is uh Jesus is not is not also God.
If you're claiming that. Okay, so Allah
and Jesus are not God together. I never
said so. Allah Uh-huh. Allah Allah is
God, but what you're saying what you're
saying in your own in your own words in
your own words because you also claim
that Jesus is God, but in your own words
Jesus is not God.
If that should be the case. But to me, I
fully agreed and I'm and I'm proud of
being a Muslim. Allah is God now, today,
tomorrow, next tomorrow, and uh until
the day is going to until the world is
going to end. But you believe in a God
that's not all powerful. So, by
definition, he's not God. He's not all
powerful. He can't do all things. He
can't have a son without a without help.
If that's If that is your definition If
that is your definition of all powerful,
then that is that is left for you.
That's what being all powerful is.
Having You you you have no limits to
your power. You're able to do all
things. Don't don't you agree, Ezri? Uh
let me ask you. So, what is the most
powerful being in for you?
God. Uh-huh. And who is God to you? So,
God is the God is the being
Listen, guys. God is the being that is
able to do all things including having a
son without depending on someone outside
of himself to have a son. He could do
that if he wanted to. But that's not
Allah. Allah can't do that. He needs
help. So therefore, he's not God by
definition. That is what Yusuf is also
asking you to your own Then who is God
to you? Who is God?
But before we go on to my belief, Yusuf
agreed with me that if Allah of the
Quran needs help to do something,
then that would mean that he's not God
because he's not all powerful. Yusuf
agreed with me on that earlier.
Remember, Yusuf?
What? Remember you and I agreed together
that
that God can do all things and that if
he needed help to do something, then
he's not God, right? Remember we said
that? No, Yusuf never said that. No, you
Did you just hear him? He said he just
said yes. I did I I did I did not hear
that from him. Well, he just said yes.
He told you that if he wants to, he
could. No, that's what he said. No, he
didn't. See? So he agreed that if
there's something that God that Allah
cannot do by himself and he needs help
to do it, then he's not God. But you're
saying So you're you're saying, "Well,
yeah. Allah would need a wife to have a
son, so he can't have a son without a
wife." So there's something he can't do
by your by your standing and you're okay
with it. You're proud of that. Fine,
that's fine. Hold your position.
So both you and Yusuf are Muslims, but
you both disagree on your concept of
God. Yusuf believes God can do all
things and that if he can't, then he's
not God. You're okay with God being
limited and not being able to do all
things. So you guys have a disagreeing
on who God is. Can Can ask you a
question?
Who Who who is Who is your God? Since
you said God Since you said Allah is not
God, who is your God? Wait. Before you
ask that, can you respond to what I just
said before you try to move on? Before I
try to move on where? You are also
changing topic now. That is what I'm
asking you. I said Who is your God?
Based on your belief, who is your God?
That is what I'm asking.
Usury,
Usury, a minute, a minute, Usury. A
minute.
God what? God What is your name? God
logic, right?
My name is Avery.
is what? Avery.
Avery. Avery. Okay. Who is your God? Who
is your God?
And then we ask you first. Who is your
God? Who is your God? That is what I'm
asking. Listen to Usury, bro. Usury is
trying to tell you something. No, I'm
not listening to Usury. I'm having
conversation with you. Who is your God?
We're all We're all here having a
conversation, bro. He's the one who
advised me to bring Who is your God? Who
is your God? Why isn't he not listening
to you, Usury?
Usury, I'm asking you. Who is your God?
Can I hear Usury for 2 seconds? Every
time Usury talks, you try to interrupt
him. Let me hear Usury, what did you
say? No, no, no, no, no.
Ishaq, question. Who is your God? Who is
your God? Wait, I I didn't hear you.
Usury, what did you say? I'm also
curious with Ishaq's question. Who is
your God?
And yeah, we're going to get to that
after you guys address what I just said.
Cuz that's a different subject.
No, we've we've we've talked about it.
I'm just asking you. Since we both You
said We said You said
our our answers are not fully I've not
I've not We could come to a place that
you're going to understand us. Then we
are asking you, who is your God?
Wait, wait. We didn't finish it. So, you
acknowledge that you and Usury have a
different concept of Allah? Do you
acknowledge that?
We have We We We We did not have any
different concept of Allah. We both are
saying that Allah is God. That is what
we are telling you. All right. So,
what Watch this. Watch this.
Ishaq, watch this. Usury, can Allah have
a son without a mate? Yusri, can you
hear me? Isaac, let him let him answer.
Yusri, can Allah have a son without a
wife?
The Allah is only one.
So, how could he have partner? Could he
have a son without a wife?
He has no partner. Could he have a son
without a wife?
So, in verse 101, this verse explained
that the Lord controls everything and
direct the universe. Also stated that
Allah is all creator of everything and
is all knowing. So, Allah could not have
a son. I'll ask again, Yusri.
Could Allah Could he Could Allah have a
son without a wife? If he want to create
something, he can. Why should he need a
son?
So, is that a yes? For that part,
I can't say because it's about Iman. I'm
not really specialized in that. Ah, come
on, bro. The verse is right there. It's
either a yes or no. It's either yes,
Allah can have a son without a wife. He
doesn't need a wife to have a son. Yeah,
he can have a wife without a son.
Or it's a no. Allah needs a wife to have
a son. So, which one is it?
Could he have a wife without a son? I'm
sorry, could he have a son without a
wife or not? Yes or no?
You guys, can you
mute whoever is talking?
Moderators, thank you.
Now, Yusri, so is it yes or no? Could he
have a son without a wife?
Yes or no?
My answer is no. He can't have a son
without a partner.
Very good.
Very good. Okay, no worries. So, very
good.
The answer is no.
And you're absolutely right cuz that's
exactly what the verse says.
So, he can't have a son without a wife.
Which means he's not all powerful,
right? He is all powerful. He can create
universe. But he can't have a son
without a wife. He needs help to do
that. No, right now, you are trying to
make God to human standard.
No, I'm not. He did that.
Yes. Yes, you did it. No, Allah did
that. Allah himself put himself with
human standards by saying he needs a
wife in order to have a son. Allah did
that. I didn't do that. So, since he
needs a wife
It's It's your interpretation of
It's your interpretation of what the
Quran said. Yes. If he needs
interpretation. It's your interpretation
of of what the Quran says. If he needs a
wife And and you are not And you've not
Guys,
And we both We both me, Al-Shaat, and
and you, three Guys, please. Wait now.
If he If he
Let me ask a question. And then this is
the last question, then you can ask me
about my God, okay?
You guys got to answer this honestly,
though. If
he uh needs a wife in order to have a
son, so he can't do it by himself, is he
all-powerful? He is all-powerful.
He created the universe. How is he
all-powerful if there's something that
he can't do by himself? He needs help.
How is he all-powerful? Because it's
beneath him. Do you know what
all-powerful means? Yes. What does What
does all-powerful mean?
He can do anything. But, you just said
that there's something he can't do. But,
it's beneath him. I did say he needs
Stop. You just No, you said that there
is something Allah can't do, which is
have a son by himself without a wife.
So, that means he can't do anything,
which means he's not all-powerful,
right? Allah Allah is in Allah is
Al-Wahid. Let him answer. Allah Allah is
one. Let him answer.
not have partner. Let him answer. Yes,
Ishaq is correct. I don't care about I
don't care about that. That has nothing
to do with anything that I just asked
you. You just said that there is
something Allah can't do, which is have
a son without a wife. So, if being all
powerful means he can do anything,
but Allah can't do anything, that means
Allah's not all powerful, right?
Can I Can I Can I end this now? Can I
end this now? Let me Let me tell you
do that by answering the question? Yes.
Yes, of course. Yes, of course. If Allah
should have a son, that means you are
you are you are you are still you are
taking Allah to the human to to a human
being standard, which is not allowed.
Yes. This question you are asking is not
is not even in the way. Let me I'm I'm
so I'm very sorry to say that because if
Allah should have a son, that means you
are taking Allah to to a human form,
which Allah is not a human like me and
you. Allah does not defecate. Allah does
not cry. Allah Allah does not does not
eat. Allah is one. He has no partner. If
Allah should have a son, then you are
you are saying Allah is just like me and
you, someone that someone that is
working in
in the world. So, what you are saying is
Allah is Allah is one. So, you you are
associating another partner with Allah
is something is something different.
That is not in Islam and I'm very sure
you know that. Does Allah have servants?
Servants, yes. We are his servants. Do
humans have servants? Humans have
servants. How?
Does that mean that Allah's like humans
because both have servants? Those who We
We is servants. And those And those
humans that are that has servants also,
they We We both are one.
So, we are the ones with Allah.
Allah has servants
and humans have servants. Does that mean
that Allah is being placed with humans
because they both have servants? So, we
both we all
are Allah's servants. That is what I'm
telling you. We all
I got you. Yes. We also said that humans
are Allah's servants.
said that humans have their own servants
as well, right? Yes.
Yes, we're being in the old age.
Okay, so Allah has his servants.
Humans also have their servants. Okay,
human servants. Is Allah like humans
because they both have servants? No.
Okay, so just because humans have sons
doesn't mean that Allah would be like
humans if he had a son, too. That
doesn't just automatically necessitate
that Allah is like humans because he has
a son. Just like it doesn't mean that
Allah is like humans
because both Allah and humans have
servants. So that's thrown out the
window now. So
Wait, wait, wait. Excuse me. But but but
this is the main part. Allah's servant
is human being, angel, jinn. So what?
Who cares? Human being Human being are
Human being are not like
Who cares? He has servants. He has
servants. That's all that matters is
that he has servants.
No, the important part is who is the
servant. Okay, so what the important
part Okay, so so simple The important
part is who is the servant. So then that
would mean that if Allah can have a son,
it just matters who the son is, right?
Huh?
It would mean who the son is. It matters
who the son is.
You see You see
It seems like he's he's also running
from the question we've asked him
earlier before now. So I don't just get
it. I'm running? You are running. Yes,
of course.
Yes, of course. We asked you We asked
you the same question and you are not
answering. But you kept on asking,
asking, asking, asking. We're asking you
We just asked you simple question. Yes,
I We also said, "Who is God to you? Who
is God to you?" Since you said Allah is
not God, then who is God?
Listen, I want you to I want you to know
something about me, my my new friend.
And this is something that you're going
to You're going to see this more and
more throughout our our new friendship.
You're going to see that I am a person,
I am a young man that has OCD. I have
OCD. I have OCD regarding
switching topics. When a topic is not
finished, you get what I'm saying? When
a When a topic is is unfinished, I I I
just I feel like my skin crawls at the
thought of moving on before that topic
is complete, you know? So, that's that's
the problem that you're seeing that I
have here that's being expressed visibly
before you. And it may look like I'm
running from your question when when I
repeatedly tell you that I have no
problem dealing with your question once
we finish what we were talking about.
But, you just don't seem to get it. So,
I have to tell you my my disorder. My
disorder is I have what is called
stay-on-topic-a-phrea.
Stay-on-topic-a-phrea is what I've been
diagnosed with. So, bear with me. I
haven't taken my pills.
I haven't taken my shots and my
medicine. So, I really get agitated and
my skin crawls and I get a bad bad itch
when if I move on to a different topic
without finishing the first one. Okay,
thank you guys. Thank you for your
prayers. Please pray for me. Please pray
for me. Thank you. So, I promise, we'll
get to your question once we finish this
topic.
Okay?
I promise. Bear with me. All right. So,
our friend Houston, he said that being
all powerful means being able to do
anything. You guys both agree that
there's one thing that Allah cannot do,
which is
have a son without a wife. He's
dependent He would be dependent on a
partner, something outside of himself in
order to have a son. That means that
he's not all powerful. He He does not
have the ability to do all things. So,
he's not all powerful. If he's missing
one, you guys get it?
So, you are saying creating a new
creature is not all powerful? I'm saying
Look, let's Let me grant you that Allah
is able to create the universe and
create human beings and angels and Jin
right and create all the animals and the
roaches and the fish and all that kind
of stuff able to create all of this
stuff so he's very powerful but the one
thing that he cannot do is create for
himself a son
without a wife so that even though he's
very very very powerful
he's not all powerful he's there is a
limitation to him do you know what I'm
saying
ask you a question why would you want a
God have a son it's not about why do I
want God to have a it's not about that
it's about can he that's it just focus
on can he the fact that you said he
can't means that he's not God because
God by definition IS ALL POWERFUL ALL
powerful there's nothing too hard for
him do you know what I'm saying but you
guys are saying yes it is too hard for
Allah to have a son by himself he can't
do it so there's something that's too
hard for Allah to do which means he's
not all powerful which means HE'S NOT
GOD